all right welcome everybody the topic is
impeachment no surprise big news today
and we're going to be looking at some
video we'll be reading some articles
we'll be looking at some tweets of
course always very very interesting
tweets anytime anything is going on from
our fearless tangerine leader as some
know him I'll just wait a few moments
for people to connect and to get started
I've got I think I fixed I've got my new
graphics for live streaming and I think
I fixed there were a couple things
people were asking me to change the
other day one was the color of the bar
that gets filled in like for example if
we were to get five new members and the
bar jumps up people were saying that the
blue the other day was not noticeably
different enough from the background
color so we had that changed but we're
not it is five everybody knows that
we're starting at zero so that was
changed and then what there was one
other thing that was changed I think all
the widget graphics are working fine yep
there we go so that's all good
that one looks weird I don't know how to
change that's strange because that's not
the way that one's supposed to look but
yep all right
in any case I think that for the most
part it's a big improvement and we're
gonna have a bunch of stuff to talk
about and we'll see how long I'm here
because this it's been a very long week
we've still got the Friday show we had a
9 hour stream yesterday which was
absolutely bonkers
but I will thank people who sign up you
can communicate with me via super chat
as always on YouTube and you can ask all
sorts of different ways to send messages
over on Twitch we're hello yellow yeah
hello has signed up with twitch Prime
and so has twit and ramekin beast so
thank you all very very much ok let's
start with the news Nancy Pelosi
Democratic Speaker of the House
announcing that indeed Democrats have no
choice but to proceed with impeachment
against Donald Trump a historic step
that signals the house is increasingly
likely to vote to impeach Trump before
the end of this year sadly but with
confidence and humility with allegiance
to our founders and a heart full of love
for America today
asking our Chairman to proceed with
articles of impeachment I will actually
play the video momentarily and we will
also look at this sort of dust-up that
she had to being asked if she hates
Trump by one of the reporters in the
room we'll get to that
my prediction if I had to make one right
now and I hope that I'm wrong I do hope
that I'm wrong about this my my
prediction of the most likely outcome is
impeachment articles filed House votes
to impeach in December goes to the
Senate in January the Senate of course
is controlled by Republican senators who
have no reason whatsoever other than
morality and facts but that doesn't
really matter
Republicans who have no reason
politically to vote to convict Trump on
impeachment and then from January to
November Trump claims he was vindicated
on impeachment even though in reality
it's just Republicans that will refuse
to convict him he will try to use it to
his advantage to play the martyr to play
the victim and maybe goes ahead and gets
himself reelected in November I do not
know I am not yet taking a position on
whether that sequence of events will
lead to Donald Trump getting reelected
or to Donald Trump not getting reelected
I have no idea I'm curious to hear from
people in the audience we know Jimmy
from Philly who's sending the first
Super chat Jimmy from Philly says let's
face it David who's gonna beat Trump in
twenty honey I'm with you Jimmy i-i've
said from the start
I don't know that this helps remove
Trump and if we open up the phone lines
maybe we'll hear from Jimmy from Philly
in fact let's see if Jimmy has been
leaving any choice voicemails lately
Jimmy no longer drinking Jimmy on LSD
sometimes when he calls it now let's see
if Jimmy left any voicemails before we
move on to the Nancy Pelosi video but I
think that it's perfectly plausible that
Donald Trump gets himself reelected
after all of this for sure Jimmy did
leave a voicemail but it was two days
ago let's see if we've listened to this
one all David Jimmy from Zoey regarding
your comment president Bernie Sanders
I don't know what comment Jimmy's
referring to but we had listened to that
one already so so that's that okay
overrun twitch loves cost worry asking
could I start streaming earlier because
it's 2 a.m. in Poland well we've got
other things going on during the day so
sometimes I can't today I had to make
dinner and this is this was the earliest
that I was able to stream alright let's
go to Nancy Pelosi zijn on the
announcement that she will be moving
forward with articles of impeachment
we're gonna save ourselves 25 percent of
the time by watching at 1.25 X let's
take a listen if we began our
Declaration of Independence from an
oppressive monarch for among other
grievances the King's refusal to follow
rightfully past laws you know what she's
sounding a little bit weird at 1.25
let's just do normal I think it's we've
got plenty of time in the course of
today's events it becomes necessary for
us to address among other grievances the
president's failure to faithfully
execute the law when crafting the
Constitution the founders feared the
return of a monarchy in America and
having just bought a war of independence
they specifically feared the prospect of
a king president corrupted by foreign
influence during the Constitutional
Convention James Madison the architect
of the Constitution warned that a
president might betray his trust to
foreign powers which might prove fatal
so it sounds like Nancy Pelosi has a
cold right or is under the weather I
don't think this is normally the way she
talks to the Republic another founder of
governor Morris feared that a president
may be bribed by a greater interest to
betray his trust he emphasized that this
magistrate is not the king the people
are the king they therefore created a
constitutional remedy to protect against
the dangerous or corrupt leader aboard
impeachment unless the Constitution
contained an impeachment provision one
founder warned
a president might quote spare no effort
or means whatsoever to get himself
reelected
similarly George Mason insisted that a
president who procured his appointment
in his first instance through improper
and corrupt acts might repeat his guilt
and return to power
guys this is weird during the debate
over impeachment at the Constitutional
Convention George Mason also asked shall
any man be above justice shall that man
be above it who can commit the most
extensive injustice in his great wisdom
he knew that injustice committed by the
president erodes the rule of law
the very idea that a fair justice which
is the bedrock of our democracy and if
we allow president to be above the law
we do so surely at the peril of our
Republic in America no one is above the
law
over the past few weeks through the
Intelligence Committee working with the
Foreign Affairs and oversight committees
the American people have heard the
testimony of truly patriotic career
public servants distinguished diplomats
and decorated war heroes some of the
president's own appointees so let me
well let me just pause here if I were
giving this speech and of course that
would never happen I instead of focusing
on historical stuff I would have I would
have made it much more cut-and-dry it
still would have gone she went six
minutes I probably would have gone for
but and that was regular speed for
people who were asking that that was
that was not modified speed we'll go
back to it I would have said listen we
could be making political calculations
here but that would be wrong we could be
making election-related calculations
here but that would be wrong we could be
guessing at whether or not Republicans
in the Senate will do the right thing or
not but all of those calculations would
be the wrong ones because this is the
House of Representatives and we don't
decide about
something as serious as impeaching a
president on the basis of what our
lunatic Republicans in the Senate going
to do what is Trump going to tweet or
when is the election
it is our constitutionally enshrined
duty to be part of the balance of power
and the separation of powers and when
the facts say you must impeach we
impeach with no regard for political
calculation something like that is what
I would have gone with and I I mean
whatever is affecting her voice is just
bad timing let's continue the facts are
uncontested the president abused his
power for his own personal political
benefit at the expense of our national
security by withholding military aid and
crucial oval office meeting in exchange
for an announcement of an investigation
into his political rival yesterday the
Judiciary Committee at the Jewish Airy
Committee the American people heard
testimony from leading American
constitutional scholars who illuminated
without a doubt that the president's
actions are profound violation of the
public trust the president's actions
have seriously violated the Constitution
especially when he says and acts upon
the belief article 2 says I can do
whatever I want
know his wrongdoing strikes at the very
heart of our Constitution a separation
of powers three co-equal branches each
based check-and-balance
on the other a republic if we can keep
said benjamin franklin our democracy is
what is at stake the president leaves us
no choice but to act because he is
trying to corrupt one thing I would have
opened with we have no choice but to act
again the election for his own benefit
the president has engaged in abuse of
power undermining our national security
and jeopardizing the integrity of our
elections his actions are in defiance of
the vision of our founders and the oath
of office that he takes to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution
tuition of the United States sadly but
with confidence and humility with
allegiance to our founders and a heart
full of love for America today I am
asking our Chairman to proceed with
articles of impeachment
I commend our committee chairs and our
members for their sombre approach to
actions which other Bush the President
had not made necessary in signing the
Declaration of Independence
our founders invoked a firm reliance on
divine providence Democrats too are
prayerful and we will proceed in a
manner worthy of our offer though for
oath of office to support and defend the
Constitution of the United States from
all enemies foreign and domestic so help
us God right thank you so that's the
speech so once again I think the most
likely scenario is this month before
before we go on vacation before they go
on vacation the House of Representatives
votes to impeach January it goes to the
Senate and it goes nowhere and then it's
a matter of who can make what out of
this for political purposes for
political gain for the 2020 election
that's that's my most likely outcome
next we are going to look at this
conversation I guess we can call it that
that took place between Nancy Pelosi and
a reporter as she was exiting the
reporter is let me figure out who that I
actually have not seen the reporter
named does anybody know actually what
the name of the reporter was that she
ended up arguing with it's not here okay
we'll get to that momentarily let me say
thanks to a bunch of people Wow the only
person who has sent a super chat over on
YouTube is violently angry trumpets
Jimmy from Philly but if you have
questions or comments for me by all
means send those super chats over on
Twitch I want to say thanks to in 88
fingers for subscribing for the third
month in a row and adds the message Fox
News is still behind no doubt am i right
they are still behind Trump yes
sick man sin has subscribed with twitch
Prime and Gil 9 has subscribed with
twitch Prime as well as 503 Phoenix four
months in a row de Haan G four months in
a row Papas smoke 67 76 thank you so
much to all of you I really appreciate
that support also if you are watching on
twitch and new to twitch if you have an
Amazon Prime subscription please
subscribe to my channel with twitch
prime it's free Amazon gives every Prime
member a free twitch Prime subscription
every month it won't automatically roll
over if you did it in months past this
would be a great time to renew it for
people saying they would do it if I
streamed more often on twitch like more
than once every two weeks I think this
is my fifth stream in the last two weeks
on twitch so please no inaccuracies no
inaccuracies that would be extremely
unfair and let me thank a couple of
people
Jordan Brunson signed up at join
pakman.com and so did Steve Carlson so
that means I can now update our little
progress indicator it's gonna go from
zero it's gonna pop up to 2 boom there
it goes it just moved right there man I
love that thing especially now that
we've got a brighter color anyway if we
get to 15 I'll open up the phone lines
if we don't open up the phone lines
you're doing me a favor in the sense
that it's been a very long day but if
people want the phone lines opened I
will open them we can also you can show
your support for either twitch or
YouTube by using the coupon codes
YouTube 50 or twitch 50 and when those
are used I don't know something else
happens let's now listen to this
exchange my understanding of what took
place is as Nancy Pelosi was walking out
a reporter asked her do you hate the
president madam Speaker and she took
offense saying I'm Catholic Catholics
don't hate people as far as I've
understood let's take a look at the
video
she seems to have some kind of tremor
I'm actually noticing and this reaction
seems like a bit much it seems a bit
much powered when it comes to helping
kids or afraid of gun violence I think
he is cool when he doesn't deal with
helping our dreamers though of which
were very proud I think he's in denial
about the country about the climate
crisis however that's about the election
this is about the elect taken up in the
election this is about the Constitution
of the United States and the facts that
leads to the president's violation of
his oath of office and as a Catholic I
resent your using the word hey that
seems like too much but you know Rosetta
knew the word hits you know okay I don't
hate anyone I was raised in a way that
is full heart full of life and always
pray for the president and I'm still
praying for the present I pray for the
present all the time so don't mess with
me when it comes to words like that I
think it was a bit of an overreaction I
don't know what people think along the
same lines by the way I found it to be
let me see if I can find the video I
found it to be an overreaction the way
that the way that Joe Biden reacted to
someone let's just look at that Joe
Biden was asked a question about you
know about his son basically and he kind
of went bonkers let me see Biden
question hunter Town Hall I don't know
exactly how to find this Biden Town Hall
I think people probably know the video
I'm looking for it just happened today
okay here it has got it linked to tweets
yeah so I think that I think Nancy
Pelosi overreacted here
I think Joe Biden also overreacted here
it's not really true sentence that's not
true so that sort of seems like a fat
joke where he's the guy says I watched
it on TV and Biden says well listen I'm
not sedentary it as sort of saying yeah
I bet you're watching my son has done
anyone I did not any occasion no one has
ever said you said I setup my son to
work on an oil company then know what
you said get your work straight jack
now let me be clear this is an
overreaction but I love it this is the
this is the biggest sign of life that
we've seen from Joe Biden to use terms
that I don't even agree with using he's
being the Alpha here it's a total
overreaction but I actually I actually
like it because he's been basically
sleeping through the last few debates
now afterwards this guy was attacked and
like physically intimidated by at least
one other guy which I also think it's
stupid it's like listen he can be there
the the question was not put together
well as sick Manson is saying it was a
malformed question but it is a fair
question and actually I've addressed
this and I've seen this in the chat I've
seen it a bunch of different places the
conspiracy around Joe and hunter Biden
that Republicans are pushing is a
conspiracy theory not based on evidence
however the fact that hunter Biden had
that job is part of the broader systemic
rot that we have of this revolving door
between elected officials and CEOs and
patan and influence peddlers and
lobbyists there's no question and and I
think at some point Joe Biden may have
to account for that in some way shape or
form but you know it was it an
overreaction in some sense at the same
time I actually liked seeing Joe Biden
fired up and at the same time the guy
was asking what is essentially a
legitimate question although although
formed maybe in a way that it was not
likely to get the right type of reaction
from Joe Biden let me thank a whole
bunch of people who just signed up on
Twitch prime celery Dave and Klum a
schism aged really unfortunate subscribe
with twitch prime Quiggins prodigy
gee Bob 14 bigs lido four tracks and
she's a lion dog cheered five hundred
bits thanks to everybody over there I've
got a bunch of super chats to answer
over on the YouTube side uncie Asuma
says do you think the United States can
return to same politics meaning none
100% partisan brown-nosing no matter
what
thank you greetings from Finland well
removing Donald Trump would only be step
one and that's a much bigger uphill
battle and so I think the answer is yes
the US could return to that but it's
going to take some time let me say okay
the whole bond there's a few other super
jets here
Tyler Woodall do you even lift bro biden
2020 yeah exactly he's not sedentary
basically saying he goes to the gym Xbox
one sends a super chat another example
of answering a bad faith question Biden
should have kept walking I actually
disagree the question was was not formed
properly but it is a legitimate question
and it goes to the broader corruption
and rot that exists in politics it's not
specific to Hunter or Joe Biden that's
the reality that that I think maybe some
on the Left have not properly sort of
accounted for let me say thanks to Chris
Duffy who just signed up at join
pakman.com and Cherokee ray that gets us
to four new members
let's make the thing move again we're
gonna go from two up to four very nice
very very nice if we get eleven more
members we will open up the phone lines
appreciate everybody support all right
let's continue Donald Trump has not been
quiet today on impeachment Donald Trump
started this morning with a tweet saying
the do-nothing Democrats had a
historically bad day yesterday in the
house I don't think that's true
they have no impeachment case and are
demeaning our capital C country but
nothing matters to them they have gone
crazy therefore I say if you are going
to impeach me do it now fast so I can
have a fair trial in the Senate and so
that our country can get back to
business we will have shift the bidens
pilosa
and many more testify and will reveal
for the first time how corrupt our
system really is I think we know how
corrupt the system is I was elected to
clean the swamp and that's what I'm
doing and then two hours later the
do-nothing radical left Democrats have
just announced that they're going to
seek to Capitol I impeach me over
nothing
they already gave up on the ridiculous
Moeller stuff so now they hang their
hats on to totally appropriate perfect
phone calls with the Ukrainian president
this will mean that the beyond important
and seldom used act of impeachment will
be routinely we will use suits routinely
to attack future presidents this is not
what our founders had in mind the good
thing is that the Republicans have never
been more United we will win and then
two hours later Nancy Pelosi just had a
nervous fit she hates that we will soon
have a hundred and eighty two great new
judges and so much more stock market
capital m and employment records she
says she prays for the president I don't
believe her not even close well I
believe she's praying more than I
believe trump saying the Bible is his
second favorite book or favorite book
help the homeless in your district Nancy
USMC a just out of curiosity let's see
if Eric Trump has tweeted anything about
impeachment he retweeted Trump he
retweeted this seems like a parody but
he retweeted some Trump winery stuff can
you imagine going and getting Trump wine
it's toxic okay and that seems like he's
been a little bit quiet on Twitter there
so there it is that's what's going on at
this point and we will of course follow
it to its it's full conclusion which I
still predict will be impeachment in the
house acquittal in the Senate and then
who can use it to their advantage in
2020 if somebody says look up where the
wine is sourced from all right let's see
front wine source Trump winery oh this
this is probably gold let's take a look
at this Trump winery formerly Cluj
estate winery and vineyard is a winery
situated on Trump vineyard estates in
Charlottesville purchased by businessman
and now us
resident Donald Trump officially
reopened since 2012 it's been owned and
operated by Trump's son Eric
they manufacture 36 thousand cases Trump
has referred to it as one of the largest
wineries in the US it ranks behind two
other Virginia wineries correct manager
acquisition there's no trespassing Trump
purchased the land from Bank of America
original Trump stated publicly he owns
the largest winery on the East Coast
although politifact determined that was
not true
so on and so forth 227 acres of vineyard
so I'm not seeing anything about the
sourcing here but it seems like they're
growing the grapes in in Virginia right
unless I'm missing something there I
wouldn't be shocked if there are
undocumented immigrants working there or
something like that but yeah I don't
know what in particular I was supposed
to be looking looking at there Ginelli
nas says I'm having trouble subscribing
to twitch with prime I don't know why
you would be my understanding is that if
you are on desktop if you simply put
your mouse over the video window a blue
thing comes up that says free loot and
it should allow you to subscribe if you
are over on mobile I don't remember
exactly but people are doing it so
clearly it's working I want to say
thanks to FWC FWD scene or ACK for
signing up with twitch with a Tier one
sub smarty number one fan subscribing at
Tier one I are serious cat for
subscribing with prime appreciate that
very much thank you and I should also oh
no we're good over there okay all right
let's continue here is video of
Kellyanne Conway this morning of course
in advance of the news that they would
be moving forward with impeachment in
the house attacking Professor Carlin who
I thought testified pretty brilliant
brilliant brilliantly yesterday in the
House Judiciary Committee let's listen
to what Kellyanne had to say and one
more thing to say I want to get out
today if you ladies and gentlemen if you
went to work today
manicure nails - manicure lawd if you
went to work with a jackhammer or a well
thought machine or mechanics tools or a
carpentry belt and not three degrees
from Yale that woman yesterday looks her
nose down at you she thinks that you are
less than her and I had it do you know
why that man ran for president in the
first place for the forgotten man
forgotten woman you know why I'm still
here at the White House for you for
people who are looked down upon by
people with three yale law degrees had
the audacity audacity to say that
liberals like to cluster together and
live together
well conservatives can't even stand to
be together that's why they're scattered
I mean listen that she was not totally
off in the sense that there is actually
something to that star witness she
didn't educate us she spends her life
lecturing people she Hobnobs with the
elite well professors lecture it makes
it sound negative but that I mean that
lecture that's what you go to college
for the next generation of law of
lawyers or six figures worth of worth of
student loans to put myself through law
school and and and and and college with
my single mother working her tail off to
supplement that I resent someone like
that looking down at half of America she
sounds like Hillary Clinton with the
deployables and irredeemable and we're
sick of it and people actually Hillary
was basically right on them who are
watching you want to get the president
you want to look down on him you look
down on the people tired of it welcome
Wow completely unhinged I mean
absolutely and completely unhinged snake
sent a super chat saying what's with the
talking point about the congressman
gates accusing lawyers of having no
direct fact knowledge of anything in the
ship impeachment report yeah this is I
mean I don't even know that we want to
get into that although I'm willing to
get into it let me thank if a champagne
- champagne has signed up on my website
that's new member number five we are up
to five of 50 new members so here's the
here so yesterday there's this guy Matt
gates and in fact let's see if I can
find I think I have some video that
might be relevant just from the fool of
the he made really a fool out of himself
here's basically what Matt Gaetz said
yesterday and I don't have this clip
handy but I've got another Matt
clip handy Matt Gaetz yesterday played a
game where he asked the three or the
four but really the three witnesses do
you have any fact knowledge about what
is in Adam shifts report and of course
they don't because they weren't there
for that in the sense that the three
witnesses yesterday these these three
were the three Democratic witnesses they
were there yesterday to explain given
everything that has been asserted would
that mean Trump is impeachable they're
there to contextualise the evidence
that's been asserted in what the law and
the Constitution say with regard to
impeachment they weren't there to be
fact witnesses they're not there to tell
you whether everybody who testified in
the house Intel committee two weeks ago
lied that's not what they're there for
so Matt Gaetz played a game that was
probably sort of effective with trumpets
because I heard this being floated
around inside in the YouTube comments
today saying none of these witnesses
asserted any facts well they asserted
their interpretation of the Constitution
and the law which is what they were
there to do they weren't there to say
Sundlun was right when he said there was
a quid pro quo they were there to say
given what has been testified to this is
what the law and the Constitution would
say about what's supposed to happen with
impeachment let's now go let me see what
the time code is here got to 24 actually
let's go back a little bit we're gonna
start us or Noah Feldman who's brilliant
by the way about some article he wrote
then he will go over to Professor Carlin
and ask her about political donations
take a look and then mr. Jake Flanagan
wrote in in courts a Harvard Law
professor thinks Trump could be
impeached over fake news accusations my
question professor Feldman is since you
seem to believe that the basis for
impeachment is even broader than the
basis that my Democratic colleagues have
laid forward do you believe you're
outside of the political mainstream on
the question of impeachment
I believe that impeachment is warranted
whenever the president abuses his power
for personal benefit or to corrupt the
democratic process did you write an
call entitled it's hard to take
impeachment seriously now yes I did
right
so one of the things that I hate is that
gates and other Republicans other than
just yelling the entire time which is
really annoying they ask questions that
warrant more than a yes or no answer and
then complain that they're running out
of time and then they interrupt the
witness election House Democrats have
made it painfully clear that discussing
impeachment is primarily or even
exclusively a tool to weaken president
Trump's chances in 2020 did you write
those words until this call in July 25th
I was an impeachment skeptic they're all
changed my mind sir and for a she ate
your testimony professor Carlin you gave
two thousand bucks or you gave a
thousand bucks to Elizabeth Warren right
I believe so
you gave 1,200 bucks to Barack Obama I
have no reason to question that and you
gave two thousand bucks to Hillary
Clinton that's correct
why so much more for Hillary than the
other two because I've been giving a lot
of money to charity recently because of
all of the poor people in the you
have you ever been on a podcast called
versus Trump I think I was on a live
panel that the people who ran the
podcast called versus Trump on that do
you remember saying the following
liberals tend to cluster more
conservatives especially very
conservative people tend to spread out
more perhaps because they don't even
want to be around themselves there is
nothing wrong with that I mean listen we
know that why is there an urban rural
divide well because liberals and
conservatives have different preferences
about where they want to live right
there's nothing wrong with that and if
she wants to jokingly speculate on a
podcast maybe they just don't even want
to be around each other because they
can't stand each other there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing it just
it doesn't hurt her credibility about
what the lies did you say that yes I did
do you understand how that reflects
contempt on people who are conservative
know what I was talking about there was
the
natural tendency if you put the quote in
context the natural tendency of a
compactness requirement to favor a party
whose voters are more spread out well
and I do well your he's slinging
horrible accusations and then not
letting her answer and so I just have to
say when you talk about how liberals
want to be around each other in cluster
mister servitudes don't want to be
around each other and so they were just
true now it makes people you may not see
this from you know like the ivory towers
of your law school but it makes actual
people in this country
actually he he interrupts her consulate
this this guy's disgusting okay just one
other example of another thing that
backfired here's Tom McClintock asking
the whoa asking people on the panel to
say who they voted for and they smartly
say we don't have to tell you that Thank
You mr. chairman just with a show of
hands how many on the panel actually
voted for Donald Trump in 2016 silence I
don't just say anything about how we can
start balance just short pants I will
not I think you've made your positions
professor Carla suspended will suspend
the clock - how many of you clap your
staff at the moment you generally may
ask the question the witnesses don't
have to respond correct
how many Trump in 2016 show of hands not
to keep not raising our hands is not an
estimation of an answer sir this is all
they had when all you have is when the
facts aren't on your side you just find
questions to try to impune the character
of the witnesses that's all you do
j-money Jay with a 1999 super chat over
on YouTube what evidence does Nancy
Pelosi have for impeachment of Trump
when her obsessive topic is back to
Russia just to smear the president is a
democratic party that desperate that
they are not confident in their
candidates yes I mean I mean to some
degree yeah and I think it was a mistake
to
the impeachment inquiry from the
beginning and then now you're hearing
them talk more about Russia even though
that's not actually what was
investigated I think it's a mess and I'm
worried that it will backfire although I
hope that it does not Sherri Todd sends
a super chat to say my last super chat
had a typo I hate that all right well
I'm glad that you corrected him and Matt
H says via super chat Sam cedar or
vermin supreme for libertarian nominee I
met vermin on primary day in New
Hampshire in 2016 and I think I have a
picture with him on my um I think it's
on my Instagram actually it was if I
recall I was only just getting on
Instagram then if you go to David Pakman
all the way to the end of my Instagram I
think I have a picture with vermin at
the very very beginning it takes a while
to scroll all the way back there but I
am slowly doing it let's see here well
it's a I don't remember if I think I
asked him to take the boot off of his
head vermin supreme is this perennial
candidate who often wears a boot on his
head and I think I asked him to take it
off for the picture man I've posted a
lot to Instagram it's taking me a while
to scroll all the way back yeah my first
picture ever on Instagram is me with
vermin supreme let's see if you can see
this if I hold it up yeah there we are
there's me and vermin anyway why would
we on that oh right the superjet Daniel
Krieger says the clutching of pearls
about Baron Trump was funny it was yeah
it was just such an so not a big deal
and Steve G sends a twenty dollar super
chat thank you all right let me thank
some folks over on Twitch I want to say
thanks to gin Jah for subscribing for
five months in a row with the message
the Republicans keep being dishonest
about the impeachment process how can
the Democrats combat this it is hurting
our electorate it you can't the the
right has something they didn't during
the impeachment potential of Richard
Nixon which is Fox News and Rush
Limbaugh and right-wing media awesome
al 360 has subscribed with twitch prime
n t FN has subscribed with twitch prime
Fried sickle has
for the four months of four months in a
row with twitch Prime with the message
she is a living SNL skit I don't know if
you mean Professor Carlin or Nancy
Pelosi darlin Jen has subscribed with
twitch Prime I appreciate that thank you
so much and Michael chambers is a new
David Pakman show member Frank litter Co
is a new david pakman show member and
minerva growl has signed up at join
pakman.com so we are going to go we're
at five and we are going to eight very
nice if that's for opening up the phone
lines if folks want me to open up the
phone lines I'm glad to do it sort of I
mean I'm tired it's been a long week but
I will do it I will do it I got a
voicemail from a guy Oh actually maybe
you guys would be interested in this
this is kind of funny there's a guy who
called in yesterday to my show named
total control 871 and he has been I
think he didn't like how it went and
he's been leaving angry voicemails ever
since so I'm going to play for you the
voicemail that or the phone call rather
that I had with him because I think it's
actually hilarious he made an assertion
and then was unable to defend it and
then he got really mad at me let's take
this has not published yet 6:09 area
code who is calling today from 609 hey
what a fact my total control is everyone
how you doing good what's going on
alright so a couple observations here
arm I believe that the media movement
has done more damage to women than help
them in terms of this election cycle so
I do believe that what I believe women
have indeed been victimized by men for
centuries but quite rudely in some cases
mm-hmm but I believe that women in the
meter movement in their newly acquired
power to terminate powerful men on
accusation alone he said she's
accusation alone it's left them a little
power drunk I think and I think that's
translating in the polls and with the
voters
think that people just simply don't want
to bring in a woman president right now
just remember this guy after this phone
call won't stop calling saying he so
embarrassed me that you know what you
will you'll see or leak for this
election cycle
so total don't let me see if I stand
because you're saying a lot I want to
make sure I understand it you're saying
that the the women can that it's
currently running like for example
Elizabeth Warren or Kamala Harris who
dropped out or Tulsi Gabbard Amy
Klobuchar they would have more support
today if men hadn't lost jobs because of
allegations of sexual assault is that
your assertion no my assertion is this
women or to be more specific if the me
to movement had been a bit more
responsible with their newly acquired
power that's what I'm saying what's an
example and irresponsibility of the use
of the power of the me to movement well
complete no no due process like a yeah
but what's an example of the power being
wielded
what's that what's of what's an example
of that power being wielded
inappropriately he said she said right
but look like slam cases if there's some
cave to go but total or the meeting to
learn his name hold on talk about Flores
with her hair sniffing claim that was
pretty uh crazy I'm not mistaken which
story a staffer had a grimace on his
face the entire time that he was pretty
much being forced to cover it so you're
saying the female Democratic candidates
aren't getting more support because of
CNN reporting about Lucy Flores no
that's what you're saying day but I've
already said what I wanted to say but
it's pretty obvious that you're not
really happy with what the narrative
that I've crafted here and that's okay
you don't have to anyway how about if we
move on to Donald Trump because I heard
a couple of interesting nicknames for
him
my nickname is Agent Orange and the pun
is intended okay good yeah we've heard
that before so all right so
we're running low that time I'm gonna
let you go so anyway so after this
happened he's just been leaving
voicemail after voicemail like this one
the transaxles ding dongs in disguise
chicks with dicks rage their battle to
destroy evil cause right then he called
again David now you really ought to be
ashamed of yourself
I mean you the king of corporate videos
crushing up little guys so in the
narrative isn't going quite your way you
act yeah like a child so there was that
and then called again this one's just
many of our myth huh boy total control
yeah so no shortage of anti-semitism
either probably won't shock anybody okay
so anyway that's that let's move on mind
of the North Star sent a super chat many
say I am now a centrist neoliberal shill
simply because I pointed out Camilla's
decline in the polls started well before
her exchanges with Tulsi I'm sure you
couldn't relate to this yeah I mean it's
true her decline started what we can
look at the polls in fact Kamala Harris
at one point I think hit fifteen percent
but it's taking just a second to pull
this up
here we go I think we're getting closer
to pulling it up okay
this is just going really slowly I hope
this isn't my connection hmm maybe it is
very odd stream is good again okay
anyway so Kamala Harris as you can see
he or she hit about 15% and the decline
started right away the Kama love Tulsi
thing I think happened on November 20th
which is November 20th is here yeah so
it's just it's a it's an undeniable
reality that the decline started much
much before the Tulsi stuff
Rowdy for 22 says goat g-o-p hated trump
first look at Lindsey on CNN Talk
yeah I'm not I'm not sure what that's
about but I will certainly look into
that
Imperator mal says hey David love your
show keep up the good work thank you
very much appreciate that
okay let me say thanks to a few other
people over on actually I don't have
anybody to think over on Twitch but I do
want to say thanks to Monica Pat sir
Monica Pats are signed up at join
pakman.com is new member number nine we
are just six new members away if people
want to open up the phone lines if six
folks sign up at join pakman.com info is
up there and it's all very very exciting
although I don't know why it says save
45% that's weird it's only 40% with that
coupon there we go
but I'll give you an even better coupon
if you use the coupon last 20 19 that'll
save you 60% take advantage of it if you
would like ok other questions that were
coming in oh yeah it was lagging I
apologize something weird definitely
happened but I don't know it seems to
have been fixed at this point in time
okay a few questions over on Twitch am i
familiar with the works of analytic
philosopher doctor
Nik gnam he's a self-proclaimed leftist
and has done a lot of work in the field
of the me2 movement I am not I'm not
feathery no coperino says Democratic
Party are all sheep easily manipulated
people voting for Biden conservatives
are super based and went for Trump
before Fox ever pushed yeah another
message from someone who's this tulsi
gabbard all right thank you and some
people said that a commercial played
over on Twitch I don't know I haven't I
haven't pressed anything I don't really
know the purple Party of Canada via
super chat says purple progressive
utopian reform projects for a liberated
earth question will you consider running
for office next cycle I had a very
interesting conversation with a
Massachusetts political strategist a few
months ago asking me about a particular
seat that he thought it should be I
should consider running for but in news
related to running for stuff
Genki ogre who is running for Congress
is going to be appearing on the show
sometime soon epic fails says hey David
what do you think the Republicans would
do if Trump had a real health scare on
live television I don't know what they
would do I don't know I'm guessing Fox
News would cut away from it but
otherwise I'm not I'm not really sure
what it is that that they would do they
would probably try to explain it away
and maybe even show video of Hillary
coughing or something like that that's
that's my guess for what they would do
let me say thanks to ms juxta who has
subscribed with twitch prime very much
appreciate that
and no people asking if I was oh you
know what there's a guy we've got a ban
this guy's so annoying
let me just ban a couple people here
there's actually a lot of people that
need to be banned the great thing about
banning people is that it's free it
costs us nothing all right very good i
just banned a few people because there's
just some people that are that are being
oxic in the chat and we don't we don't
really want that some people saying I
should interview ana kasparian instead
of Genk well Jenks running for something
Jacob ball coming in out of nowhere with
a $50 super chat along with I guess
what's called a super sticker who even
knows what this stuff is but YouTube has
this new thing I guess called super
stickers I appreciate that and I want to
send just a massive thank you to celery
Dave celery Dave just gave out ten
subscriptions over on Twitch and that is
absolutely and completely stunning and I
really appreciate that Steve G says
Biden legitimately mentioned the record
player he's out of touch sniffs hair hmm
I'm not sure I know what that means but
it is interesting
DJ senpai says David please go on trains
podcast tonight he's familiar with the
work of Tyler nickname listen I don't
know who Tyler nickname is and I don't
know what train is so you know I don't I
don't don't know about any of this stuff
so I don't I never know when somebody is
suggesting I do something say something
or talk to someone extremely racist so I
always try to be careful a DD says I
used to be yang gang but I admit that he
needs to drop let's see how Andrew yang
is doing in the latest polls let's take
a look here yang so he's at 2% in the
Economist 2% in the hill 4% in Politico
3 percent in the previous Economist poll
2% in Quinnipiac yeah I mean listen I
understand staying in for as long as you
are able to make the debates
let me see democratic debate wiki let me
see who's actually in or close to in I
actually respect Kamala Harris because
she was in the next debate but decided
to drop out anyway because she's not
raising money and has no path to the
nomination I respect that because it's
very appealing to just get the stage
time right yang okay so Andrew yang has
qualified based on donor criteria
has not qualified based on polling
criteria and has not qualified based on
early State polling criteria so Andrew
yang may not make the next debate and at
that point it does become sort of a
question mark let's look at the early
states in Iowa yang is most recently
polling for okay that's something
although in some of these others he's
polling one in New Hampshire yang is
polling five four and two okay
in Nevada yang is polling three 1 and 3
and then in South Carolina yang is
polling 4 or 0 depending on which poll
you look at all right so it's not
looking great for Andrew yang I don't
know I think if he doesn't make the next
debate it does start to become a
question how long he how long he sticks
around Keith Cole says David any quick
book recommendations for us yes what I
am reading right now I just started this
let me find it I am reading this book
right here killing Pablo by Mark Bowden
it's a nonfiction book about the sort of
history and eventual downfall of Pablo
Escobar really really good excellent
book I think it's even won some awards
let me see here maybe not excellent book
though so I'm reading this I'm also
reading principles of life and work by
Ray Dalio he wrote a very very good book
just a couple of years ago and he's a
super interesting billionaire I actually
find him as a billionaire I find him
much more interesting than some of the
other folks that are billionaires and
I'm reading that as well I can fully
fully recommend that to you monie Lew 78
sends a super chat David do you plan to
come out with an app for the David
Pakman show
unsure unsure RM Brown says what's your
favorite youtube channel besides yours
it's mostly like chess channels honestly
like I've taken lessons chess lessons
with a guy named Eric Rowe
and I watched his videos I'll watch
Hikaru
I wonder actually if Eric let's just see
if by chance he's streaming on twitch
right now because I've never caught one
of his live streams on Twitch I guess
he's not know
anyway it's mostly stuff that people who
watch political things probably wouldn't
hurt wouldn't have heard of a joke
crowfoot says you shouldn't dismiss the
gabbard effect on Kamala she tanked
after Gabe bird dunked on her in the
July debate
please be accurate okay I thought you
were talking about something too I
thought people were talking about Kamala
attacking Tulsi not Tulsi attacking
Kamala but I apologize there Imperator
mal David did you see the Howard Stern
interview of Hillary Clinton
excellent fascinating interview doesn't
change my view of Hillary's politics but
it was yesterday on the Howard Stern
Show and you should definitely listen to
it if you have access robert rousey says
do you think camel is decent dissent was
directly related to her centrist pivot
yeah I think that what Kamala Harris is
descent or downfall was really more
related to was being slippery on health
care and coming in with these planned
attacks that you know fell a little bit
flat I think that there was more to that
really than anything else let me say
thanks to Antoine mazza Rekha for
signing up for a David Pakman show
membership as well as Jessica Sanchez
and Jordie Jordan that's three more
three more new website members that gets
us to 12 out of 15 I actually may end up
having to open up the phone lines I was
almost getting ready to go to bed but it
seems like you find folks might actually
make me open up the phone lines which
would be totally fine would be totally
fine David have you considered speaking
with Yuval noah Harare and Anand
Giridhar das I already interviewed Anand
Giridhar das you can check out that
interview and we've invited you've all
know a Harare I would love to have him
on but he is unfortunately not responded
to any of
request sadly it makes me sad makes me
sad
let me say thanks to one of the Smurfs
for subscribing with twitch Prime and
also thanks to horoscopes and I got
karma to collect for the bits logan
Ensley says via super chat yang should
run for a congressional seat what do you
think David I think that he would have a
great shot I think that he would have a
great shot at a congressional seat if it
was the right one and I look forward to
interviewing Genki augur about his run
for Congress upcoming very soon as well
we're trying to work out a date and it's
going to happen pretty soon yeah listen
Hillary said a lot of things I disagree
with on her interview with Howard Stern
I don't deny that but it was the most
humanist most humanist most humanized
I've ever seen Hillary Clinton for sure
okay let me see here I need to ban just
a few other people let's see here
there is one and okay yeah I mean it
listen we're not gonna tolerate
anti-semitism in the chat to the extent
that I see it Charmander says what is
the best argument against Medicare for
all so I'm for Medicare for all I'm for
Medicare for all I'm in favor of
Medicare for all I believe Medicare for
all is the gold standard I believe
Medicare for all is the proposal which I
would most like to see made the law
hopefully I'm being clear for me the
strongest criticism of Medicare for all
is that it I'll it is incorrect to
presume a 50% decrease in the cost of
delivering care merely on the basis of
switching to a Medicare for all paying
system and a lot of the plans that I've
seen assume that we will reduce our per
capita healthcare spending to the level
of Canada and Australia the the best
estimates I've seen say that could take
15 to 20 years to happen I'm for
Medicare for all I support Medicare for
all it's way better than the system we
have I hope Medicare for all becomes the
law okay
I think people people get the point
oh I just missed another question that I
wanted to answer Justin Mehmet
Justin Mehmet has signed up at join
pakman.com and that gets us to 13 look
at that 13 out of 15 new members if just
look at that it's just this little thing
right here if two more people were to
sign up we would open up the phone lines
right there because we've got all of
this versus only that it's hard to do
this looking at yourself reversed anyway
I also want to say thanks to Latrice Taj
for signing up at join pakman.com I'm
gonna you know I was looking forward to
going to bed but it looks like the phone
lines are actually gonna get get opened
up
they aren't open now and I see so many
people that are continuing to call in
and leave voicemails the phone lines
have not yet opened to be totally clear
Jimmy is out of control bastard
it used to be ten new members to get a
calling yeah right well that's because
we're streaming on both YouTube and
twitch so the threshold is up here's
Jimmy again back with Jimmy from Philly
you cheap [ __ ] fifteen cars used
to be paying you cheap bastard alright
so that's just another version of the
same call a DD sends a super chat
triggered unsubscribed Charmander says
medicare-for-all equals 40% doctor pay
cut would it really save dollars for
everyone yeah we've we've talked about
that already before so I don't want to
go fully into that because we've talked
about that so many times that I don't
want to turn this into a
medicare-for-all stream but yes I'm for
medicare for all thank you very much I
very much appreciate it I see a whole
bunch of people saying they can't figure
out how to sign up with twitch prime on
Twitch so step one are you an Amazon
Prime member if you are you have to link
Amazon Prime to twitch Google that
connect Amazon Prime to twitch Prime and
then it should be really really easy
there's like a purple button somewhere
or something like that I don't
exactly where it appears or if you're on
desktop just put your mouse over the
video window and there will be something
that pops up that says free loot user
says Camila dropped out because she
didn't want to be on the California
primary ballot and get destroyed
deadline is soon her re-election is 2023
David Pakman in YouTube chat people are
asking how to subscribe with twitch
prime okay
if there's anyone watching this on
YouTube trying to subscribe with twitch
prime you can't do that I did not even
it didn't even occur to me that that's
something people might be trying to do
twitch prime is on twitch twitch prime
is on twitch twitch TV slash slash David
Pakman alright Raoul Curie no Kirino has
signed up at join pakman.com that's 15
so let's open up the phone lines let's
do it because it happened it happened
let's do it six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty if folks want to
call in I will take some phone calls
oh also thanks to Nathan Davis and Rick
sack ow who have also signed up now
let's see what happens what happens if
we go over this is the first time this
has happened with my new graphics if we
go over 15 let's see 17 or 15 oh nothing
happens it just says 17 of 15 and the
bar is filled now I wonder can I
immediately change it to 15 of 20 Oh
beautiful
alright let's just do that the new goal
now becomes 20 why not right let's get
set up for phone calls here the number
is 6 1 7 thank you for calling in to the
David Pakman show
8 3 zero please do not use speakerphone
47 15 ready and listen for David to call
out your area code 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is
the number we're gonna have a good time
here talking to some people we're
talking about impeachment we are talking
about many many different things but I
will take questions about all of it
let's just go first to Jimmy from Philly
because he's been going completely
cuckoo for cocoa puffs Jimmy what's
going on are you on LSD right now I am
NOT ok
yeah I am NOT but daily yeah you know
this is what kills me yeah you talk all
this socialist stuff right
oh no I'm not associated in the second
Jimmy let's back it up let's back it up
Jimmy I I'm not a socialist I'm not back
it up David you're gonna get bite me now
I know can you cite one socialist
position I've advocated for president
Bernie Sanders you-you-you pronounced a
position you say advocated for position
you said president Bernie you like
Bernie Sanders I'm a brilliant guy
neither or socialist you know so let's
get to the point here so David you went
from 10 new members to 15 for calling
that's a capitalist view I'm a
capitalist yeah so capitalism works work
quite well for you when you were to make
more money accidently 15 what's that
forty five dollars and we're I'm all for
you I mean yeah come on David yeah now
in the future I would like to be you to
refer to me as an angry psycho no it
Trent
Krampus so Jimmy if I understand
correctly you called in to say that I'm
a socialist but then you then eisah
explained I'm a capitalist and then you
accuse me of actually being a capitalist
so it sounds yeah you're not
accomplished David David David David I
said gaslight come on come on but you
just called me you're talking to me not
talking to your subscribers David I
forgot to tell you I've been meaning to
tell you this and I forget every time I
talk to you did you know that my
daughter just got accepted to Harvard I
did not know that your science Norris
aren't congratulate our strange but
we're estranged but yeah yeah the kid
the kid got a big brain she got yeah
yeah how did you find out if I may ask
how did you find out given that your
estranged oh that's my hat I had
somebody go on her on her mother's
Facebook and her mother's Facebook has
Harvard mom and all this and and I went
on Julia's Facebook and that
she just posted one little thing about
Harvard
you know like gee the kids not real big
she's very humble I mean the kid yeah
kids never miss a day of school she's
she wants to be a scientist and Jimmy I
I mean I'm really sorry I'm really sorry
that you're estranged from her why how
did that happen I'm curious well you
know that email I sent you right with
all that you know I mean no I want to
put it out but uh would email but the
mother to the mother was a 50-day
drinker much worse than I ever was I've
never had to be detox but but Jimmy if
her mother drinks how did you get it how
did you get us all trained oh I say
what that she so the mother was drinking
and made claims about you the mother
made a bunch of false claims which I was
exonerated after 18 months yeah she sat
through the baby on the floor her 20 the
kid was 9 months old there was no
evidence in this right but did you do it
aside from whether there was evidence
did you what
aside from whether there was evidence
did you do that did you throw a baby on
the floor no of course not even my cab
when she was five years old she said
daddy wouldn't I have gotten hurt if you
threw me okay you would think you know
but you know that's the way the court
system works today David if a woman said
something or even a man I mean if you're
the first one to make the accusation
that's what they go with Jimmy let me
ask you this I'm curious walk and talk
Jimmy have you have you um have you been
arrested before what were the charges
what were you arrested for the day and
with violence against any 40 years ago
this was 35 years ago
no violence against anybody now Oh wit I
mean just generally speaking what kind
of a thing was it let's take that theft
and we're firearms but I don't want to
make that as an excuse because you know
I was guilty as hell
and you know that sets up mom crab oh
yeah but you know I'm not doing that now
I mean yeah here's another thing so I
was an idiot over twitch Prime but
you're getting all these calls about
yeah like they don't understand twitch
pride but I was it [ __ ] yeah do not
alright Jimmy Jimmy I'm feeling bad
about all this it's a sad situation I'm
an atheist you're an atheist right yeah
yeah yes you're an atheist right so how
come you didn't come at this closely
thing where she said she's a Catholic
and she doesn't hate anybody
how come you didn't come at that from
the atheistic point of view oh yeah why
you'd get a pat all right Jimmy very
good we'll listen I hope that all the
mystery I hope they reconnect with her I
do hope you reconnect with her all right
thank you very much Jimmy from Philly
somebody please clip that somebody
something something sad about that call
today let's go next to our caller from
the 508 area code may be a local caller
from the Massachusetts area 508 you're
on the air yes hello oh I don't know you
know I taught there a few semesters ago
and I'm quite frankly so insanely busy
that I don't know when I'm gonna be back
to teaching I loved it but it's just
I've got so many things going on and a
lot of travel upcoming and so I don't
know I don't have an answer for you how
long will you be there oh man oh wait
for you
all right good hopefully we'll have an
opportunity all right okay thank you
very good let's go to our caller from
the 3:05 area code I always I tend to go
to 305 because I just love Miami Miami's
one of my favorite places in the country
305 what's going on hey David can you
hear me yes I got
Hey I just had a question about debates
like YouTube do it like political
debates do you see value and in debates
in general and I just wanted to get your
take on debates overall I'm in favor of
debating ideas the only me - the only
thing that I see that's kind of weird
about a lot of kind of YouTube political
debates even even the presidential
debates is that there is a performative
aspect to it a lot of the time it's just
the person who is kind of the best
personality wins I don't know what do
you think about that
absolutely heavy on that it is and the
format requires that because you get you
know 30 seconds to respond 45 seconds so
people come in with you know planned
kill shots like when you know when
Kamala came in planning to call Joe
Biden a racist or when Cory Booker came
in ready to tell Joe Biden that I
thought he was high when he said that
marijuana is a gateway drug it lends
itself to that it's unfortunate it's
unfortunate but you know the other thing
is you've got to clear the stage a
little bit to get more substantive
debate unless you want it to go 10 hours
if you want to get substance in two
hours you can't have 1012 people on the
stage yeah totally totally agreed one
last really quick thing I think the
thing that people are saying giving you
a hard time about the health care thing
I haven't heard like pretty much any
leftist podcast or anything like that
that hasn't said the exact same thing is
that there's not a lot of hope that it's
gonna be that we're gonna get a
universal health care plan like anytime
soon so I don't think that that's a
warranted attack just just to say that
and I was just curious why you think you
got blowback on that I don't know it's
really popular right now to do out just
outrage you know to be outraged at
things and to attack people and whatever
and it sounds like so windy where you
are but I think we are we are gonna be
able to appear super-severe
so I don't know I think you know one
thing I have noticed is that the bigger
my channel gets the more people attack
me and the more we get brigaded when we
don't say the right thing as far as the
left is concerned but it is what it is
you know I mean
we've had are we in the last 30 days
we've had our our four best days ever on
YouTube have all happened in the last 30
days you know we're picking up thousands
of subscribers and III think that we're
just gonna keep doing what we're doing
if people don't agree with me all the
time that's fine it doesn't seem to be
hurting the channel or the show and I
want to just say say things the way I
see them you know oh also I've noticed
like I don't know if you've noticed this
but on YouTube kind of like new
independent news channels it has a kind
of reader it used to redirect to other
you know other of the same chant other
videos of the same channel but now I
kind of read at least for me a redirect
to mainstream yes and that's NBC and
stuff like that yeah that started we
have a big report about that that
actually started several months ago and
we're seeing a lot of it yeah I
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much hope to hear from you again let's
go - lets go to Sam from the - OH - Sam
from the - OH - what's going on hi in my
life right now
you are live right now you talked to
John Gardner again and I love that guy
yeah please try to bring him on more
okay and I thought just occurred to me
that no one no one is talking about
who knows if Trump is elected again
where he will be at the end of this
towards the end of the second term
because we've already seen him go
downhill absolutely couldn't agree with
you more Sam who who knows also on the
light I wanted to end with another thing
with that video you posted about like
the back last year and you know let's be
practical about Medicare for all so I
feel like I mentioned like the Bernie or
bust people previously and I think these
are the same people just a lot of these
same people who took your
medicare-for-all video out of context
you know I just think you have I'm sorry
I'm sorry you just have some people who
are just kind of a stuck in
our own little box absolutely Sam Sam
thank you so much it's always such a
pleasure hearing from you let me say
thanks to hard revenge for subscribing
for five months on Twitch with the
message tell Jimmy to subscribe to
twitch I also want to say thanks to 12th
dimension for subscribing with twitch
prime lil money t-dub simple Zack 12 P Q
coyote Vlad Nix Napper Sounion I think
that's it
let's see let's go next to let's go to
country code 35 this could be crazy
country code 35 who's this Finland I
love it where are you calling from
Helsinki or elsewhere I'm from Helsinki
but currently I'm working this weekend
away from Helsinki in the western part
of Finland got it I was enough in sinky
in the last year and I absolutely loved
Helsinki yeah mystery in the summer and
winter but then maybe the spring and
fall are pretty awful of the weather but
during the winter time in summer time
it's very nice yeah I took like a little
boat ride over to an island that has a
brewery on it does that ring a bell
yeah it's right in the center near the
president's palace right they call yep
great food yeah now let me ask you a
question when I was there I was just
loving this salmon chowder sort of soup
that is popular there do you know the
dish I'm talking about yeah with famine
and potatoes and yes now do locals
actually eat that or is that basically
tourist food I know locals make it like
it's a very traditional Finnish
beautiful I love it
all right good well I've taken up enough
of your time I'm guessing you had
something you wanted to talk about you
visited Finland
and I lived in California myself for
five years under it was I I think it was
very similar and a bit different in
California but then both of my sisters
they studied one in Massachusetts and
then the other one in Buffalo for
college and when I visited there and
I've been around the states in different
places I really noticed it's a very
different country around like so I was
my question is what do you think are the
main things that you would think like
the US could learn from Nordic countries
such as Finland
oh my goodness we should be looking at
Finland for I mean it's like where to
start obviously your health care system
is better the way that new parents are
supported by the state is much better
we've covered on my show you know this
sort of kit that new mothers get with
the basics which have been figured out
like if you start Parenthood with these
basics the kids gonna be way better off
everybody gets that more respect for
time off and separation between you know
work and not work I mean there's just so
many things yeah yeah I agree with
especially like the mother kit it's kind
of funny when you explain it to
foreigners but it's not unusual for like
a lot of my friends and stuff like you
know the first place where you flip as a
baby what's the box that all the stuff
came right weird yeah for people who
don't know what we're talking about
this is a box new parents get and the
box itself can be a crib if you don't
have one I mean it's really pretty
brilliant and I think if I recall
correctly it's only about 200 euro worth
of stuff but it's really important stuff
yeah well it's mostly like if you think
that of course people usually are very
prepared when they're having a kid but
usually you might forget something right
it has all the basic needs once you go
home from the hospital to be able to
handle handle that even have the basic
need indeed
hey last Finland question do you go over
like is it a fun thing that people do to
take the boat over to Tollan for like
the day and then come back is that
something people do yeah
usually when people go to tahleen it's
the day cruise and then they'll go on
because alcohol is way cheaper yes way
cheaper there and then they bring
alcohol back to Finland yeah we took the
cilia line
we took a cilia line boat over and there
were people who were saying we're coming
right back on the next one after buying
a bunch of alcohol yeah yeah and and
then more of like touristy thing which
is people go to Stockholm from helpp
unbootable those are usually two day
cruises or two night cruise it's just to
get away well I hope to get to Stockholm
soon I really appreciate the call okay
watch it here usually I listen to it
daily while I'm driving so keep up the
good work thank you very much all right
I hope to hear from you again
let's go next - where do we go there are
so many people holding let's try our
caller from the 909 area code who's
calling from 909 oh hey how are you how
are you good awesome cool it's awesome
to be on here it's crazy that I'm not
actually I don't really have much today
probably cut this much cut this part
short that's true that did happen yeah
but I'm fine thank you cool cool I had
one other thing survive in Cairo watch
it you know I don't know the answer
because
I don't have any contact with the
advertisers we have an ad sales person
and when they tell me record an ad I do
it and I don't actually know when the
ads air so I'm not sure okay maybe I
shouldn't save my opinion on this then I
don't want to get you in trouble ringing
all right okay okay cool well all right
well that's really all I had to say I
agree with everything you say and love
it I really appreciate you so uh thanks
all right very good
got a gut through a lot of topics though
I appreciate that okay let's go next to
our caller from the 203 area code who's
calling today from 203 a lot of nice
people calling in today yes that's you
it's you yeah Oh son of a show thank you
yes I'm just trying to reroute my brain
yeah I recall I think it was probably a
month or two ago I saw that he made a
pretty good video illustrating the
differences between Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren and if I remember
correctly most of the information in the
video pertain to actual policies on what
you saw were different between the two
of them and the thing that I kind of I
felt at the end a little bit like
something was missing but well I just
remember you ending the video saying
that the topic and I apologize if this
is going to be like the topic of a
future video but you said that the the
the strategies that with Warren and
Bernie Sanders would have to actually
get these policies interaction in office
I would have to be something that will
be discussed another day it was
something something like that something
along the lines that um who would be
more effective at actually getting their
political go getting their policies to
actually exist and I I thought that was
something like curious because to me
when we're talking about Elizabeth
Warren Bernie Sanders I feel like that's
the that's the sort of like crux of the
issue that's the biggest thing that kind
of separates it to do and I was kind of
always waiting for that videos to come
out because I was really interested in
you also take us through whether a more
sort of reform the system candidate
versus and you know a little bit more
kind of revolutionary candidate like
Bernie Sanders like what differences
between these two in terms of how they
would get their policy into action like
I understand okay I think I think I get
what you're saying so yeah so number one
when I say something is a topic for
another day I don't necessarily mean
it's a topic for me for another day I
just mean it's a different topic than
the one I'm talking about but in short
it's basically a question between the
more revolutionary approach or the
incremental approach so let's say that
one is more progressive than Warren and
is more in line with Bernie's policy if
there's a debate to be had and I'm not
picking a side in the debate as to
whether in practice Elizabeth Warren
might move the country more to the left
because while less progressive she's
working more within the system whereas
Bernie wants to change the system that's
the argument now I'm just the messenger
there I want to make make that clear but
that's the basic question mark that
that's the the difference in
implementation right yeah and I actually
Oh although I feel like a lot of Bernie
Sanders supporters I feel like mmm kind
of take it for granted that his approach
might actually bring America to the left
because obviously he is he's pulling a
little bit more from the left and then a
little before and there I I actually I
feel like progressives are maybe they're
a little bit too quick to sort of
denounce incrementalism like and
entirely and I get it in the sense that
I suppose whenever we think of
incrementalism we kind of think of
centrism or sort of like it just not
being enough
because obviously America caused a lot
of problems today but but yeah other
people people can certainly disagree
about that hey I'm curious are you like
maybe British but you move to the u.s.
pretty young yeah
I'm kind of I'm kind of from all over
I'm actually that you had the previous
caller I think from Finland or something
I have roots in Finland Peru America on
England but I just moved
I just finished University University in
England yeah if I could get like one
point across really quick because I just
want to say I am like a Bernie Sanders
supporter and for me it almost I just
really think that the fact that someone
is actually trying to build lots of
grassroots support in the country and
trying to bring democracy back in the
hands of people I think it's more
valuable than a lot of policy discussion
in itself and maybe that's not as a
smartest way to think but I very much
appreciate what someone like Bernie
Sanders is doing in America and it's
made me a lot more interested in
politics I'm not an Elizabeth Warren
hater I like but I just really like
Bernie Sanders I think there are two
really great candidates but Bernie's
just a little bit better all right very
good point taken I appreciate the phone
call thank you so much and it is a
position that will be pleasing to some
and very concerning to others
all right thanks to everybody who joined
me that is it for me today we've done I
think like 12 hours of streaming this
week which is a lot for us although I
know some people do this every day but
that's going